hi guys it's me Megan Monroe we're in
state three and I'm gonna make some
salsa to remind me of California
[Music]
welcome to Wuhan quarantine day 8 so
I've been doing some research about
Wuhan because there's more to the area
than just the virus there's over a
hundred and sixty links in Wuhan alone
and this one is called Sanjay who which
means triangle or Delta Lake so we're
staying inside for the next two weeks
staying safe and Wuhan we're with you I
just wanted to say that everybody's
scared of the virus everybody here is
doing what they can to protect
themselves and their families and
helping others our neighbor is a doctor
he's been bringing us food and everyone
as I can tell is staying inside I'm in
the lobby of my apartment right now this
is the lady that works at the front desk
and we're not afraid of the coronavirus
I've been through a lot of stuff in my
life I went through this winery was
scary in elementary school and in
Northern California and during college
ends of two different fires chatter
welcome to day 11 of the Wuhan
quarantine I just wanted to say that I
came to China not only to teach but also
to learn about the culture which is
pretty easy to do when everybody's
freaking out about a virus
um there's another plane that's going
back to America and I've decided against
going on it because I'd rather be in my
apartment alone as opposed to being on
an airplane with 200 possibly infected
people today is beautiful and sunny
compared to the brain yesterday so I
decided to come to my office which is in
the same apartment complex as my
apartment and give a little bit of work
done we've been offering free classes to
our students so that they can keep
learning pronunciation and public speech
and another thing that's SuperDuper cool
is if you look right over here there's a
brand new hospital that Wuhan built it
seats a thousand people and it's just
about two lakes
way so stay safe have a wonderful day
and Luhan we got you I've been spending
my time inside learning just a little
bit of Chinese and I wanted to share it
with you
so first I learned how to say shisha
which is how you say thank you me how is
hello da Bao bei means big baby because
that's what I am and Wuhan Jo
which means come on a move on everybody
have a wonderful day stay safe and hi
guys it's me Megan Monroe States 17 of
luhan foreign team today's the Lantern
Festival so we're supposed to be eating
mochi soup but I decided to make
scrambled eggs and self I hope everybody
takes care and safe today and have a
lovely day
[Music]
welcome to day 19 of the Wuhan
quarantine today I wanted to talk about
three different problems that I've had
the first one is the fact that a lot of
people are asking me if I'm sick the
answer is yes I'm sick of being stuck
inside all day I go to the grocery store
but not really anywhere else
the second big problem that I've been
facing is the fact that there's no
Mexican food in China and I'm sure that
the quarantine is just making it worse
but I have yet to find Mexican food in
China the third problem is the fact that
with all the shops closed I haven't
gotten my haircut in about a month and
so I need somebody to come and tame this
beast anyways I hope everybody has a
wonderful day stay safe stay warm and
Luhan Jo I came to China so that I could
ultimately live my dream and become a
theater and dance teacher for little
kids and I'm just gonna stick it out
because I'm bigger than this virus it's
not gonna get me I have my whole life
ahead of me so I hope everybody has a
really nice day stay safe and we'll
chayo hi guys it's me Megan Monroe
welcome to day 21 of the Wuhan
quarantine we have to get a paper now so
we can sign out of the gates where our
apartments are and they can only let us
out about once every three days so
that's gonna be a little bit crazy but
stay safe and have a nice day no matter
what I learned this tongue twister two
days ago when I first went live she put
down
boo-boo toffee boot cheap without doubt
to boot out Pete welcome to day 30 of
the Wuhan quarantine I said in one of my
other videos I'm learning how to speak a
little bit of Chinese so da Bao bei
means big baby and I call myself a da
Bao bei because I'm very cute and sweet
and I really like things that are small
so this is a normal sized strawberry
stop Bao bei so I hope everybody's
having a great day I'm feeling a lot
better because I got a lot of fresh air
today
[Music]
yes I'm actually inside us otherwise I
wouldn't be holding this fish and that
sign right there would be English not
Chinese so please stop doubting me or
I'll come hit you with this fish welcome
to day 38 of the Wuhan quarantine the
way the groceries get delivered in my
area is someone will come from the
outside and drop a bunch of them off at
the basketball court and then volunteers
will come and distribute the food like
what I did the other day but today I got
something very very very very important
I got this huge bag of bread I've
already eaten two donuts and a cream
cheese roll and I promise I'm not gonna
eat it all today
I swear that would be a bad idea anyways
I hope everybody has a really awesome
day stay safe stay tight Luhan jo it's
me Megan Monroe and I made ribs and
they're delicious hi guys it's me Megan
Lynn Roe welcome to day 39 of the Wuhan
quarantine my parents sent me a care
package about a month ago and I finally
got it just the other day it had a beans
and rice and salsa along with masks and
hand sanitizer I ate the beans and rice
up very very quickly because I was quite
excited but it also came with my
favorite pepper Chinese
pickles and as you can tell I really
really like pickles it's only been about
five days I have no shame but I wanted
to give a big shout out to Mike DD and
Molly Monroe I love you all very very
much and thank you to everybody on
tik-tok who's been supporting me but if
you're one of the people that's in the
comments telling me wish I was dead cut
it out that's not cool I hope everyone
has a great day though hi guys it's me
Megan Monroe welcome to day 42 of the
wuhan quarantine so I've been reading
the news and apparently the virus has
spread to America Italy Korea and Japan
among other places so if you have a
stuffy nose or you're sneezing you
probably don't have the virus but if you
have a dry cough and you're having
trouble breathing
I get checked out like I said a new
beginning for everybody in rouen now it
applies for everybody around the world
stay out of crowded places wash your
hands wear a mask and hope for the best
anyways full world new hug Jo we've had
to go back and forth picking up
groceries today
so we're just trying to hang in there
and not get too tired and also like when
people go bursary shopping usually they
make a list for the entire week so that
they can get a big thing of groceries
and I want everybody in Wuhan to do that
so that we don't have to keep going back
and forth and going the volunteers Luhan
Dre yo it's beautiful outside it's sunny
I'm having a nice day but there's a lot
of volunteers who have to sit outside of
buildings and we're going to pick up our
groceries right now volunteers help with
that too so we have to go back and forth
because we placed a lot of orders today
but that's gonna be fun we're getting
eggs and I'm having a nice time
[Music]
you
[Music]